facts are under attack and the barbarous
tyranny of feelings is ascendant we will
analyze a wonderful cough FA weekend of
some of the fakest news yet total self
humiliation by the mainstream media CNN
Washington Post New York Times oh my
then the great Victor Davis Hanson VDH
helps us kick off our new segment this
day in history on the anniversary of
Hitler's dumb decision to challenge the
red white and blue don't be like Hitler
stick around these colors don't run
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
you know there's a meme going around
it's been going around for a while which
is literally Hitler so you'd say you
know Donald Trump cut taxes he is
literally Hitler Donald Trump thinks
that Supreme Court justices should
respect the text of the Constitution
he's literally Hitler you know any
trivial thing that you don't like
becomes literally Hitler well today is
different we are going to talk literally
about Hitler with today is the
anniversary of Germany declaring war in
the United States one of the worst
decisions of the war Victor Davis Hanson
the Martini Lee Anderson fellow at the
Hoover Institution has a great new book
that just came out about this the second
world wars so we will talk to him but
before we get to Hitler literally Hitler
we have got to talk about something
slightly less awful just slightly which
is the Democrat operatives who pretend
to be journalists on television let's
begin with CNN CNN exclusive in the
Russia investigation an electronic trail
has emerged showing a possible attempt
to share hacked WikiLeaks documents with
the Trump campaign let's get right to
CNN's Manu Raju with these breaking
details Lana what have you learned
well John Donald Trump his son Donald
Trump jr. and others in the Trump
Organization they received an email in
September 2016 offering a decryption key
and website address for hacked WikiLeaks
documents now this is according to
September 4th 2016 email provided to
congressional investigators by the Trump
Organization now to put the timeframe in
context here this email came months
after the hacked emails of the DNC were
made public and one month before
WikiLeaks began leaking the contents of
Clinton campaign chairman John Podesta's
hacked emails and shortly before Trump
jr. began an exchange of direct messages
on Twitter with WikiLeaks now
congressional investigators are trying
to determine whether the individual who
sent the September email is legitimate
and whether it shows additional efforts
by WikiLeaks to connect with Trump's son
and others on the Trump campaign you saw
that that that looked like a news report
that sounded like a news report right
it's got the guy in the suit
it's got the chyron z-- and the backdrop
and everything it looked like a news
report it reminds me of that stupid ad
that CNN put out and said this is an
Apple it looks like an Apple it is an
apple
that was that's like CNN but it is that
wasn't a news report do you know how
much of that was true how much of what
they say they were saying it so soberly
straight-faced very serious
breaking news exclusive you how much of
that was true none of it that wasn't
true that's fake news CNN reported that
Donald Trump and Donald Trump jr. were
emailed a link from WikiLeaks or from
someone connected to WikiLeaks days
before WikiLeaks were leached the batch
of emails to the public so there it is
that's the collusion we've been waiting
for all hear it we finally got the
smoking gun
forget Van Jones said Russia is a
nothing burger forget James Comey under
oath said that most of these stories are
nonsense
we've got The Smoking Gun so CNN's Manu
Raju Jeremy heard their report we now
have the first evidence that Trump's
campaign was given advanced info on
WikiLeaks stolen documents from
Democrats and there's just one problem
with that report which is that there is
no evidence that Trump received advanced
information on stolen documents from
Democrats other than that other than the
content of the report that was totally
right but except for the reporting that
that was wrong but it looked right it
looked like the news it even it was on
television like the news is the guys
wore suits like the news do even the
Washington Post left-wing as can be
democracy dice darkness or whatever even
they pointed this out they were the
first to call at CNN for this fake
report so CNN reported that the email
the awful email saying that WikiLeaks
did all this was sent on September 4th
that was nine days before WikiLeaks
released it turns out though the email
was really sent on September 14th that
one digit makes a big difference
ten days later that was after WikiLeaks
had tweeted out the info this was
completely publicly available
information WikiLeaks in that tweet said
678 megabytes of DNC documents from
gusoff ur and here's the password and
here's how you unlock it right they gave
everything that's in his email that
WikiLeaks had tweeted out already so the
email came from this guy Mike Erickson
we don't I've never heard of Mike
Erickson before so CNN's report
insinuated that Mike Harrison Ericsson
might be a Russian agent now I don't
know I didn't look into a guy so let's
do five seconds of research
turns out he's not turns out after I'm
just getting it in my ear they're doing
five seconds of research and yeah turns
out that guy is the president of an
aviation management company but I guess
CNN doesn't have asked access to Google
you know or doesn't they don't have
telephones where they can call people
and check any of their facts so instead
they have to suggest that Mike Erickson
is a Russian agent and and completely
screw up the dates so it goes from being
I guess sort of a story to being nothing
to being WikiLeaks sent out a tweet and
a trump supporter forwarded that tweet
to them and said hey look at this you
know like just friends do it's like the
chain email or something but do not
worry it gets better not only where the
email dates completely off undermining
the entire story but as Trump juniors
lawyer explains quote the email was
never read or responded to which the
House Intelligence Committee knows so
Donald Trump juniors lawyer had a
masterful response here and this brings
up some questions he said quote the
email was never read it responded to the
house Intel committee knows this it is
profoundly I've lost his I've lost his
line here it is profoundly disappointing
that members of the House Intelligence
Committee would deliberately leak a
document with the misleading suggestion
that the information was not public when
they know there was not a scintilla of
evidence that mr. Trump jr. read or
responded to the email so not only did
they get it completely wrong there isn't
any evidence that they even saw this
thing now this raises a question
especially for the political operative
types who don't think that there are
really any such thing as coincidences in
politics who leaked it Donald Trump Jr's
lawyer says it was a Democrat on the
House Intelligence Committee who would
have access to this testimony and this
information I suppose it could be that
but as the Daily Caller reported how CNN
got its report so wrong is unclear so
one has to wonder was it a Democrat on
the committee who saw the emails who
heard the testimony and then that
Democrat just got it completely wrong or
was it a Republican was it someone
around the Trump administration the
Trump apparatus who leaked it
knowing that CNN would never
it's due diligence would never check any
of its facts would breathlessly report
this thing and then look up look
humiliated when it came out that this
wasn't true hard to tell we're posing to
difficult interests against one another
Democrat incompetence and Republican
strategy I don't know I don't know which
one I believe I guess they're not not
mutually exclusive but if I had to
gamble here I would suggest this might
have come from the Republicans because
every effect of it was so beneficial it
totally knocked CNN for a loop Donald
Trump was ready to go to slam these
people the Trump lawyer was ready to go
to slam them so I don't know it looks
like they may have gotten taken
advantage of the tactic has been used
before you'll remember on my
doppleganger Rachel Matt as show she was
boasting we have the Trump tax returns
we have them someone gave us the the
envelope and then when she read it on
air it proved that Trump had paid taxes
it completely destroyed their narrative
and they got got that got had because
they didn't do their due diligence and
Republicans plotted and planted
information there that might be the case
here I'm not certain of that 55 45 6040
but I wouldn't be surprised
now the fake news does not end there
over the weekend I don't know how we
didn't work we should have come in and
done show Washington Post does not get
off the hook it's true they called out
CNN for pushing fake news but they don't
get off the hook the Washington Post's
Dave Wiegel posted a screenshot of an
auditorium before a Trump speech this
was a tweet and he wrote on it
sarcastically
packed to the rafters did you get it
because it was empty dude that was the
pictures showed that it was completely
empty so do you get it it's really funny
isn't it except it turns out it wasn't
so now as Donald Trump responded he said
Dave Wiegel Washington Post put out a
phony photo of an empty arena hours
before I arrived at the venue with
thousands of people outside on their way
and real photos now shown as I spoke
packed house many people unable to get
in demand apology and retraction from
fake news wopo so in his defense
Wiegel did apologize he responded he
said sure thing I apologize I deleted
the photo after David Marcus ko
a conservative journalist told me I'd
gotten it wrong was confused by the
image of you walking in the bottom right
corner now what that really should read
is somebody called out my fake news and
now I've got to move on to the next
dirty trick so I'll admit that you got
me on this one but you know he did
apologize for posting him but his
apology missed the missed the whole
point so how did the Washington Post
which reported all of this how did they
respond how did they cover this little
dust-up here's the headline quote
President Trump calls for Washington
Post reporter who apologized for
inaccurate tweet to be fired completely
misses the point it is not just that
it's an inaccurate tweet sure it's an it
is inaccurate he posted fake news but
it's the arrogance it's how smug it's
how condescending it's and it's
inaccurate that's on top of it it's the
packed to the rafters t he he isn't that
guy what an idiot Donald Trump is
tee-hee-hee but behind my I'm a
journalist I'm from the coasts I'm
really cool I'm on my computer I'm so
much smarter that's the fake news it the
fake news isn't that the tweet is
inaccurate the fake news is that Dave
Wiegel is a journalist rather than an
activist the fake news is that the
Washington Post is an objective news
organization rather than an activist
group for the left now by the way this
is a pattern with Wiegel he in recent
years he's tweeted out that any who
oppose redefining marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions or bigots
he's regularly disparaged members of the
conservative movement on Twitter like
Matt Drudge he violated Washington
Post's guidelines asking journalists to
refrain from posting anything that could
show bias or favoritism that hasn't
stopped any of the rest of them so I
don't know why we should hold him to a
particular account and in wiegel's
defense his job is to mix opinion and
journalism that's in his contract he has
to provide analysis and some opinion but
the reason that the Washington Post has
moved in that direction is the reason
all news outlets have moved in that
direction it gets views it's very
popular we like to see some opinion with
our reporting plain reporting is boring
but that means it's no longer news it's
fake news some outlets like The Daily
wire not to enable gays but we're very
straight for
with our point of view we have a point
of view we have certain political goals
some are shared some are different and
we just tell you this is the lens
through which we're looking at the world
and we're looking at the news Washington
Post doesn't do that they have pompous
preening moralizing slogans like
democracy dies in darkness
Dave Wiegel doesn't even tell you that
the CNN doesn't tell you that CNN
employs a Andrew Klavan calls him Fredo
Cuomo you know Chris Cuomo these
Democrat operative hacks George
Stephanopoulos and they pretend to be
news that is it if any Democrat tells
you that fake news is just an empty
slogan or it's just an attack by Donald
Trump that isn't the case we're not
talking even about the stories we're
talking about the attitude of the
outlets now for straight-up false
reporting we would have to turn to Brian
Ross at ABC News Ross incorrectly
reported on Friday December 1st that
President Trump directed Michael Flynn
to make contact with Russian officials
before the election now in reality not
not in the ABC reporting but in reality
Trump had actually asked Flynn to make
contact with Russia after the election
when he was president-elect this is a
slight difference before the election or
once the country has voted him in as
president and it's not just Ross it
isn't just that he misspoke or something
which I think some people tried to say
ABC also tweeted the nonsense just in
they tweet Brian Ross on ABC News
special report Michael Flynn promised
quote full cooperation to the Muller
team is prepared to testify that as a
candidate Donald Trump directed him to
make contact with the Russians this was
liked and shared tens of thousands of
times before they had to delete it
because it's utterly false and ABC for
the airport refused to cop to the error
initially they said well we're gonna
offer a clarification a clarification
the thing we said isn't true I just want
to clarify I heard that Donald Trump as
a candidate told Michael Flynn to talk
to the Russkies the one edition I'll
make to that is that he didn't do that
that's the one clarification I'll make
but other than that the story stands now
they were widely panned for offering
this this clarification so the next day
they had to give out
full correction they admitted error but
only because we've been hammering the
drums only because Donald Trump himself
has been going after these Democrat
communications operatives who pretend to
be journalists for so long there's
another story in The New York Times just
came out from Donald Trump he responds
quote another false story this time in
the failing New York Times that I
watched four to eight hours of
television a day wrong also I seldom if
ever watch CNN or MSNBC both of which I
consider fake news I never watched Don
Lemon who I once called the dumbest man
on television bad reporting as a side
note thank you to Twitter for the extra
140 characters they're making these so
much they're doubling the khofifah of
them so thank you for that the New York
Times ran a report today saying that
Trump watches a lot of television and he
watches CNN and they're allegedly
talking all these people yeah the New
York Times headline is this quote inside
Trump's hour-by-hour battle for
self-preservation
that's the hour by now I'm trying to
think back on the last 11 months but 11
months he's been in office since he was
inaugurated he destroyed Isis within
within 11 months he just militarily
destroyed them he got a major tax
overhaul passed repealed the Obamacare
mandate got an originalist on the court
packed the rest of the courts the lower
courts with originalist judges has the
biggest deregulation program in modern
history Net Zero new regulations passed
per year despite an average 13,000 or so
in previous administrations it looks
pretty good to me
he's handled Syria well drop the Moab he
is handling North Korea pretty well and
it seems okay pulled out of the Paris
climate Accord what else do you want
people if that self-preservation keep
doing it man now the New York Times
reporting is not credible because the
premise is not credible you know by the
way the New York Times last February ran
a piece titled quote Trump campaign
aides had repeated contacts with Russian
intelligence which even James Comey
James coming no fan of Donald Trump you
know a Democrat hack through and through
under oath James Comey admitted
in the main that report was not true so
I don't know the report today is that
Donald Trump watches four to eight hours
of television I suppose there's no way
to know this there is a little
coincidence here because one time a
president Trump saw me on television I
was at when we were doing the blank book
thing I was I complimented him on Fox &
Friends and he tweeted a quote that I
had said and then he next endorsed the
book so I do know he watches these shows
sometimes I'm very grateful that he does
and thank you again that was a nice
early Christmas present but I don't care
how much TV he watches I don't care I'm
not convinced it's eight hours a day but
I certainly don't care if we get all of
these good things if we get the best
conservative legislation in our
lifetimes while he's watching a lot of
TV keep it up
tune in man sounds good I'll make you
the popcorn here is former Republican
former Bush speechwriter David from
explaining what we should take away from
all of this fake news you asked the
question Brian why should given these
mistakes why should people trust the
media and I say the meat mistakes are
precisely the reason the people should
trust the media the press the worst
mistakes that I'm Reagan when we talk
about the press we exclude Fox and we
talked about press organizations that
have an interest in finding truth
excluding Fox the worst mistakes that
press organizations have made in the
coverage of Crump has precisely occurred
in their effort their overzealous effort
to be a fair to the president I'm almost
speechless watch exactly you see we have
to trust the news media because they lie
to us that don't you understand you're
you're not woke like David Frum you're
probably one of those troglodyte
Republicans who's still a Republican and
didn't become woke but David from now
realizes we have to love the news media
and they have to have credibility
because they don't have any credibility
and this is the irony of the fake news
that term fake news we use it all the
time I think it was actually invented by
Norm Macdonald he used it when he was
the SNL guy on Weekend Update but it
became popularized in the days after the
2016 election to make excuses for
Hillary's loss so there was an assistant
professor of communications at Merrimack
College in Massachusetts Melissa Zim do
and she sent around a Google document
with all of the fake news websites
because they couldn't be the Hillary
lost it couldn't be that America doesn't
want her to take away our freedom and
shriek for the next four to eight years
it could it had to be that fake news
stole all of it
so she sent out this Web this Google
document and it had some websites that
are pretty kooky and then it also had
regular old websites so just right wing
websites or The Daily wire was included
on this we don't run fake stories we run
real stories we have a point of view but
we don't they're not artificial you know
they used this because they thought they
could discredit the new media the
right-wing media that broke the monopoly
of the mainstream media which used to
run the whole show until Fox News and
then it all started to crack a little
bit with the internet it backfired on
them it backfired on them because we can
check facts we have the internet we have
freedom to information and we looked
around and we saw hmm
CNN ran a completely fake story
Washington Post ran a completely fake
story the New York Times ran a
completely fake story and another one
and another one and another one who's
the fake news here and it's stuck to the
left-wing it's stuck to the mainstream
media because it's true it's stuck like
any other of Donald Trump's nicknames
that he gives to people he had tried out
a few on Hillary you know he tried low
stamina Hillary or this there that the
one that worked was crooked Hillary it's
stuck not because he kept repeating it
he kept repeating it because it's stuck
because it was true it rang true this
fake news rings true for CNN in a way
that it just doesn't for alternative
outlets that don't pretend to be
something that we're not okay should we
get into our new segment we have to get
into our new segment we have to bring on
the Nazis there is so much to talk about
but unfortunately you cannot get that if
you are not subscribed to the daily wire
so if you are a subscriber we appreciate
it you help us keep the lights on over
here if not you've got to go over there
right now what do you get well the
conversation is going to happen tomorrow
starring the one and only the Big Boss
himself
Fox News's power player of the week ben
shapiro so that will be tomorrow at 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific if you want
to ask questions of Ben he's going to
sit there for an hour
just answer the questions as they come
in if you want to ask a question you
have to be a subscriber you go to the
chat page at the Daily wire and you can
ask him whatever you like everybody can
watch but few can ask questions all are
called but many are called but few are
chosen so go over there right now if you
subscribe it's $10 a month $100 for an
annual membership what do you get you
get me the and reclaim and show the ben
shapiro show you get to talk to us all
in the conversation forget all of that
none of that matters now none of that
matters the mainstream media has
collapsed
all CNN is a tender in tears David Frum
is in tears you say they don't trust us
and you need this you need this it's not
even a choice guys the leftist tears
tumblr do not drown do not be left
behind in this torrent of salty tasty
delicious leftist tears go to daily wire
comm right now we will be right back
to fight the barbarous tyranny of
feelings let's get into our latest
segment this day in history this day in
history let's begin with the Nazis on
this day in 1941 Adolf Hitler declared
war on the United States bringing the
formerly neutral us into the European
conflict incredibly Hitler had no
advance warning of his axis partner
Japan's plan to attack the United States
German Foreign Minister von Ribbentrop
believed a declaration of war on the US
would overwhelm the German war effort
Hitler thought war inevitable so he
declared it first bizarrely blaming FDR
for the war Hitler proclaimed quote
first he incites war then falsifies the
causes then odiously wraps himself in a
cloak of Christian hypocrisy and slowly
but surely lades mankind to war but
obviously his was louder and in German
we are fortunate now to be joined by
Victor Davis Hanson the Martin and illy
Anderson senior fellow in classics and
military history at the Hoover
Institution and the author of the new
book the second world wars Victor thank
you for being here thank you for having
me now before we get into today's
significance and some of the other
excellent questions your book brings up
yd s why title the book the second world
wars rather than the Second World War
for a lot of reasons that the war was
fought from the Arctic Circle to the
Sahara and some English Channel to the
Volga River and then the Pacific all the
way from the Indian Ocean to the
Aleutians in Manchuria to Wake Island in
Hawaii so the vast canvas in which the
combatants and all but 18 countries
finally join didn't really know at every
moment who they were fighting or why I
mean nobody adventurer a Japanese
soldier in Manchuria didn't have much in
common with a Bulgarian on the Eastern
Front tired of Russians but more
importantly until 1941 and the invasion
of the Soviet Union by the Third Reich
people didn't
at World War two or in the Anglosphere
Second World War in other words there
were 10 separate Wars conducted by
Hitler and they were all except for the
Blitz against Britain successful between
September 1st 1939 and June 22nd 1941 so
that nearly 2 year period they were
known as the fall of France where the
Yugoslavian were the Greek war the
Norwegian war the Danish war but they
were all surprise attacks all successful
all against weak supposedly weaker
neighbors all within close proximity to
Germany and German logistical capability
when he went into the Soviet Union that
was quite a horse of a different color
it was a huge country had no ability to
get to Russian industry across the Urals
and then six months later when Japan
attacked us and the British at Singapore
us at Pearl Harbor then mysteriously
four days later Italy in Germany quite
unexpectedly declared war the United
States at that point this huge canvas
that just mentioned really took shape
and there was no longer a Yugoslavian
war or a Polish war it all became lumped
into the second world war singular and
World War one appropriately was now
renamed from the Great War to World War
one you know this is as you point out
the 76th I think anniversary of that
declaration of Hitler declaring war on
the United States you know just shortly
four days after Pearl Harbor why on
earth would a Dolf Hitler already in the
midst of his Wars that he's fighting why
would he declare war on the largest
economy in the world
well it didn't make any sense and it
surely doesn't make any sense now I also
put people at his General Staff key
military advisors not only didn't know
that he was going to do it but objected
vehemently when they found out about it
so we have to put ourselves in his
mindset he was inordinately impressed by
naval power because his fleet was a
fraction
sighs with British fleet and he felt a
Japanese fleet which was third largest
in the world and comparable to the
American Pacific Fleet would so tie down
America that they would not really be
able to fight a two-front war and he
felt that Britain was dormant he hadn't
controlled what his own what we would
call now the European Union and he
really only had one front and that would
be against Russia and when he declared
war on December 11th he was at the first
subway station outside of Moscow so on
his way of thinking very shortly
Moscow Lin rather than a halt I'm going
to finish the war Britain will be
isolated the United States is going to
have its hands full effort lost its
fleet at Pearl Harbor and my u-boats
will be right off the coast of Miami and
for the first time in two years they
could really go after these fat targets
that will cut the life line off to
Britain and therefore the war will be
over six months British will start
Russia will fall the United States won't
come to terms with the Japanese in terms
of did he have any idea of the fleet
that was being constructed in u.s.
dockyards in 1941 no did he have any
idea of it at World War one the United
States had delivered two million men in
less than 18 months no did he have any
idea that the United States would create
130 aircraft carriers or a bomber an
hour he had no concept of that and as
people tried to explain to him even
people like Goering the marshal Baluch
waffa that if you're getting yourself
into an existential war it's quite
different than border wars
and he said mindfully we have no ability
to bomb Russia beyond the Urals we were
not able to shut down Manchester and
Liverpool in London industry and we
surely don't have an ability to go to
New York or Detroit or Oakland and yet
that's fell on deaf ears and by a by an
existential war you mean
war that can't be solved with a little
treaty and leaving the government in
place you need to totally force the
country into submission and
unconditional surrender and that hubris
that you described in Hitler is I
suppose unsurprising I was thinking to
myself that the axis power is not being
able to collaborate or to coordinate
with one another shouldn't be so
surprising Nazis and racialist
totalitarians are not the easiest people
to share and get along but it's
unbelievable that Hitler did not know
that his partner in Japan was going to
attack Pearl Harbor
then the betrayal of the Soviet Union
there was no coordination with Mussolini
to what degree or one yeah to what
degree what does that inability to
cooperate did that affect the outcome of
the war well it did a great deal because
they all have shared fascist ideologies
and you think they would have
coordinated in a way that British
imperialist American Democrats and
Soviet communists would not but all the
major division decisions on the Allied
side unconditional surrender a second
front in Normandy strategic bombing
campaign Linley's were all mutually
agreed upon and they were coordinated
and one importantly the Allies shared
expertise if we had a p39 Airacobra that
we didn't feel was very good but
although it was excellent for anti-tank
warfare then we gave it to the Soviets
who found it quite useful if we had a
Sherman tank that really couldn't knock
out a panther the British came in and
said let's put our 17-pounder on that
turret or if we had a p-51 that was not
flying as fast as a focke-wulf the
British came in and said great airframe
wrong engine we'll put a Merlin engine
and made the best fire of the world
there was no such sharing of information
among the fascism and that they really
hurt them and in the case of Pearl
Harbor the Japanese were very angry at
the Russians because right when they
were fighting Stalin in 1939 in August
and part of the fascist war Global War
what they fell against communism hitler
cut a deal with Stalin Molotov
Ribbentrop pact and that made that freed
up Russia's western flank worries about
it and the Japanese is sued for peace
they paid the Germans back in April of
1941 on the eve not too long six weeks
before Germany was going to go into
Russia they cut their own non-aggression
pact with Stalin and that free about 25
divisions on the east shores of Russia
and boundaries to be used against the
Germans so there was nothing but
suspicion among all three of the Axis
powers I suppose it's not a surprise if
your partners are fascists that you
might be suspicious though it is
impressive that liberal democracy is
able to work with was able to work with
Stalin so well one of my favorite lines
in your book is you say quote we often
forget that the Third Reich was
postmodern in creative genius but
pre-modern
in actual implementation and operations
and it reminds me of that scene in
George Bernard Shaw us back to
Methuselah where the serpent says to Eve
this is frequently quoted by Democrat
politicians like the Kennedys but he
says you see things that are and ask why
I dream of things that never were and
ask why not to what extent was Germany
and Adolf Hitler were they the victim to
their own fantasies and delusions well
the entire Nazi ideology was built on a
sort of a hodgepodge of Nietzschean
Superman crackpot philosophy vogner's of
operas and the drama that they had never
been corrupted assimilated and her
married integrated with the Roman Empire
that they turned up upside down in Roman
history that being on the wrong side of
Dan you online was the right side that
they were there for a voc term that
meant not just you were German Ares you
would live in Germany or spoke German
but you'd look this particular way and
out of that sort of crackpot idea that
a month with the other one German was
worth three or four Russians or
Americans or British and that meant that
they never really looked in a very
pregnant until Albert Speer the
brilliant engineer of Russian industry
and central planner of a German industry
came into power in 4243 did they ever
look at a cost-benefit analysis so where
the Allies said here's a b-17 here's a
Lancaster bomber here's a b24 here's a
b-29
this is how much money it costs to
deliver one pound of ordnance so many
miles against the enemy now what are the
alternatives they said we're going to
have a cruise missile v1 or an
intercontinental business to be -
they're the latest technology we're
going to have a mission at 262 jet and
they just looked at performance ability
in isolation or high tech in isolation
or they looked at a tiger 2 tank they
never had they said well this has an 88
millimeter barrel has six inches of
armor egg weighs 65 tons they never
asked themselves how many hours can that
tank operate per hours of maintenance
whereas that's all we talked about
Sherman one out one hour of maintenance
$10 on the road b-29 20,000 pounds you
can deliver much cheaper than it b-17
and so when we did things at the
Manhattan Project to do 29 projects they
were grounded in common-sense pragmatism
maintenance durability and they live in
a world of fantasies whether it was huge
rail comes like Gustav it took 7,000
Germans to shoot one shot one projectile
every three minutes and after 180 they
walked barrels had actually no effect on
on the war the Japanese building Musashi
and the Yamato the two largest
battleships in the world between them
sank one light carrier when they could
have used resources to build 50 of the
world's best destroyers they have great
destroyers to have enough of them if
they were they didn't want to build
things really bad they're going to be
really high-tech
well that old stereotype we have of the
Germans as you know they're very
efficient those Germans are a very
efficient people but the portrait that
we get out of your book is of a
passionate Hitler yeah Hitler who is
given to his own ideological wackiness -
given to the the blunders that come out
of his own ideology about his people and
this brings up the question of what
precisely was the main decider of the
war what was the biggest influence you
write ideology for good or evil
was a force multiplier of German
Japanese and Soviet armies but obviously
they lost so what was the relative
importance of ideology air land and sea
military superiority and economic output
finally on the outcome of the war
once Hitler and the Japanese redefined
the war as really the big thick Italy
Germany in Japan against the Soviet
Union United States and Britain they
could not win that war because they were
outnumbered by almost 200 million people
and the United States and the Soviet
Union had a larger GDP each of them than
the 3 axis put together and the United
States would soon have a GDP bigger than
all of the combatants on both sides and
it's so good Union and the United States
with each field of military over 12
million so the question was once they
found themselves and they stumbled into
an existential war could their greater
experience could the ferocity of the
Japanese or German soldier could they
had start that they had could their
utilization of what is now the entire EU
under Third Reich occupation and most
much larger area in the Pacific from the
shale oil fields in any Mesa to the
Malaysian rubber plantations to the rice
Felton's healthy seeds could be use all
of that and defeat the Allies before
they geared up and for a while it looked
like they could it's if we were to ask
this question and
almost at 1942 the 6th army was just
about ready to crush the Russians at
Stalingrad Guadalcanal had been occupied
and was cutting off Australia from the
Americans Rommel had taken to Brooklyn
was on his way to Suez thinking he could
link up with Army Group South in Russia
and then suddenly that fantasy vanished
with the 1st Marine Division just wiped
out the Japanese on going to canal when
a series of five naval battles be
destroyed a great portion of the
Japanese fleet no need to talk about
Stalingrad they lost the entire 6th army
of 300,000 veterans and then Rommel was
stopped El Alamein had to flee all the
way back into Libya and Algeria and of
course quarter-million people would
surrender the next summer so at that
point it was just a question what are
the Allies want to do they can they
defeated the axis tactically but do they
want to have an armistice like World War
one or do they want to have an
unconditional surrender they have had
one on conditions rather they have to go
to Rome Berlin and Tokyo and destroy
these people's political system was 15
million enemy soldiers in the field I
was going to be very costly that's
mostly the war of 1943 44 and 45 and and
before that the Axis powers were doing
very well but they had the advantage of
constantly surprising people they would
there was a series of surprise attacks
sucker-punches in the field of war and
yet then the mongrel Americans and the
decadent British and all of these
countries that the Germans would have
called decadent were able to rally a lot
of economic and military output
how did to what degree did the Axis
powers rely entirely you know or majorly
on surprise and how did decadent nations
defeat the ideologically disciplined
axis I think the answer is that they
were ideologically but they weren't
discipline so if you look
until 1944 per-capita expenditures on
military affairs munitions soldiers as a
percentage of GDP was much greater in
places like Britain on the Soviet Union
the United States and it was not just in
Jef Japan but Germany as well so you
have Americans working cold decadent
that were not having women wear nylons
where Germans were still wearing nylons
and we were having paper guides when
people in Germany were not saving paper
that changed by 44 and 45 but we really
geared up people always look at Britain
as sort of a weak link but during the
Blitz of September of 1940 the British
were they lost 50 cals and dead they
were under attack they were producing
more supermarine spitfires per month
than the Germans with all the current
today EU under the control of producing
bf109 fighters so we kind of forget that
the Allies just made a lot more
sacrifices they were a lot more
practical and pragmatic in their
approach to war and they were not
blinded by ideological zealotry and
speaking of some of those sacrifices now
particularly when we talk about the war
in the Pacific when we talk about the
war in the Pacific there is a atone it
seems of apology Barack Obama but
implicitly if not explicitly went to
Hiroshima to apologize for the dropping
of the bomb and yet as you write the
Japanese were butchers during the war
they killed many more than were killed
themselves why is it that when we when
we discuss the war in the Pacific there
is such a feeling of sympathy or apology
toward the Japanese it's hard to know I
think part of where the Chinese Theater
was really unknown to the west and some
fifteen to seventeen million Chinese the
vast majority of them civilians were
butchered by the Japanese who then
killed another four to five million
civilians in the South Pacific in other
areas of Asia and then they probably
killed you
camps civilians are in combat another
five to six hundred thousand Australians
Americans and British and I guess the
idea was it because we got the bomb and
it was a nuclear bomb on Hiroshima
Nagasaki that just ended discussion and
we forget sometimes that the 65 million
people who were killed will work through
about 80 million
excuse me eighty percent of them about
fifty million and that would be the six
million
who'd lost their lives in the Holocaust
so three or four million civilians and
Yugoslavia in Poland the 27 million dead
of which probably somewhere around 16
million in Russia were civilian the 16 I
mentioned the other civilians in Asia
we're all killed by Germans and Japanese
soldiers and World War two we should
remember was one of the few Wars history
where the loser is lost far left and did
the winners and basically it was a story
of German and Japanese soldiers killing
people in Eastern Europe Russia and
China they didn't have any weapons and
we're not in uniform and so when Obama
said that in this apology you think well
what were the Japanese thinking when
they know on their own history that in
terms of how my day lost versus how many
they kill they were the most murderous
combatant in the entire war and that all
of these dead people 50 million dead
people were killed by these two
countries and that we're showing
deference to them because we ended the
war end of the misery Roshan my Nagasaki
and by the way that would that was true
because it wasn't that we tried to state
it off an invasion as this is largely
caricatured but we had the entire bomber
fleet that had been idle for three
months in Europe 10,000 b-24s b-17s
British Lancaster bombers all we're
going to be at least a large part
transferred to Okinawa which was owned
not like the Marianas 1,600 miles of
Japan but 380 miles and Curtis LeMay
could envision dropping a more napalm
which had already burned out 65% of the
urban core of Japan
but dropping more net explosives and
napalm about every two weeks alone the
power of one atomic bomb and so that was
all called off by the atomic bombs and
LeMay sort of said well I don't know why
we had to drop them I had I had a fleet
in mind and air fleet that would have
devastated Japan ways that no atomic
bomb could do he was right
my grandfather was a navigator on a b24
during the war over Belgium I believe in
Germany and the I've toured some of
those planes had those fleets gone over
to the to the Pacific had we not dropped
the atomic bomb I don't know of anybody
who suggests there wouldn't have been
catastrophic ly more damage and
bloodshed and this brings up a question
with the Japanese and the kamikaze
attacks specifically because you you
write that the kamikaze attacks were
cheap and effective if it didn't cost
very much to do it from a an economic
level rather than a human cost level but
paradoxically they demonstrate
desperation they demonstrate that the
enemy is so desperate they're willing to
kill their own soldiers to sink your
ship or suicide attacks ever sustainably
advantageous in war you can taken
there's a paradox in their use that can
be very effective and a cost benefit if
you have no morality about the value of
life but usually people use them in a
symmetrical fashion other words when
they're losing and because they're in
desperation so had the Japanese launched
400
kamikazes in the Battle of Midway they
would have won the war they would have
won that battle and maybe they would
have not won the war but they would have
won for two years they would have been
unstoppable because they think 17 ships
at Okinawa and killed 5,000 American
sailors worst defeat in American history
of the sea and they did so with obsolete
zeros that increase their range by not
having to have a round trip come back
home and by using some standard pilots
that all I had to do is given the plane
and died down on American you know no
dog fighting no bombing
doesn't take a whole lot to learn how to
take off you know doesn't doesn't
require as much training if you're gonna
just run your plane into somebody ship
use no fuel to clean them and the point
was that this was a cruise missile whose
human brain was more accurate than
anything known at the time and a v1 so
they were very effective but why Japan
and didn't use them earlier was they
thought we don't have to winning and
usually what happens in history when you
get that desperate atactic is very
successful is just probably it's too
little too late
the irony is it would've been very
successful but human nature being one of
these you'd never resort to that when
you feel that there's no need to no
final question is you say that world war
2 which killed 60 million people could
have been prevented how is that why is
it that wars such as this begin the axis
were the weaker powers by any standard
of calibration so at Hitler's own in
1939 in September that the Soviet Union
was distant and you know it was neutral
but not a partner or was opposed to
Germany they would have never declared
war because they would have had this
army of seven million people in their
eastern flank and them down horrible
trench arm but they had invaded
non-aggression pact so collusion was one
reason on the part of Russia the other
was appeasement and that was that
not just materially the French and
British when they saw Hitler finally in
38 for what he was they desperately
rearmed and they were very successful
they were getting close to parity or
maybe even security but they didn't they
were so common ties by World War two
that they didn't want to repeat we're
done in the film whereas the Germans who
should have been traumatized as the
losers very much wanted to repeat it
they wanted a second try so there was an
appeasement going on that Hitler
interpreted not as magnum entity to be
reciprocated but with weakness to be
treated with contempt finally the third
unfortunate leg in that that equation
was the United States was isolationist
if we had said in 1930 and I and say in
January we have an honour we have a
in alliance with France and we're going
to stationed a hundred thousand American
troops and we had mobilized Hitler with
a pepper Ghanian but it was a
combination of British and French
appeasement American isolationism and
Soviet collusion that tricked Hitler
into thinking that these countries were
morally weakened did not want to go to
war not and that diluted him to the fact
they were actually very strong countries
had already had parity with him when he
attacked them and you know and as a
result we lost 2% of the world
population
all because of isolation and appeasement
and collusion all very bad stuff a
Victor Davis Hanson professor Hanson
thank you for being here the book is
excellent the book is the second world
wars I highly recommend it we've been
talking about how nobody in America
learns history any more facts have now
been banned from college campuses and
they're deemed hateful and and bigoted
so I recommend if you'd like to refute
all of that craziness go out there and
read Victor Davis Hanson the second
world wars VDH thank you very much and
we'd love to have you back thank you for
having me
all right that's our show go out there
and get this book it's really really
good until tomorrow I am Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show tune in
tomorrow we'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Mills show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017